a busy day at Berlin's main train
station just before New Year's Eve
visitors from all over the world are
crowding into the city I'm curious to
find out what's on their minds if they
arrive here shortly after the terrorist
attack in the German capital I saw the
police so I feel a bit safe but I'm just
looking around I feel a bit uneasy and
uncertain I'm more vigilant we feel fine
but we would also try to avoid some a
lot of crowded places well we try to
avoid those places just in case that
something might happen others are more
relaxed the Brandenburg Gate is
attracting just as many people as always
some plan to spend New Year's Eve here
no one I speak to is concerned about the
possibility that something bad might
happen it ain't one of them security
measures were certainly tightened here
in Berlin after the attack I'm not
scared at all was for prowl remain
confident and optimistic keep on living
vitalina officials say that hotels have
seen hardly any cancellations since the
attack
Berlin remains a popular destination
many people are looking forward to
celebrating New Year's Eve in Berlin
despite last week's attack some are
feeling a sense of unease but they still
want to stick with their plans for the
big night the consensus is that fear
should not dominate everyday life
otherwise terrorism will have one
security has been stepped up throughout
the city not least at the Christmas
market at my child plots where a truck
drove into the crowd ten days ago will
that really make a difference though you
can't do anything about it concrete
barriers might prevent another truck
from crashing into here but something
else can always happen that's the way it
is the attack has changed the general
sense of security in Berlin but most
people are just getting on with life
because after all there's no such thing
as 100
peace of mind